il était de retour pour un week-end le
marché de Noël de Coignières a lancé les
festivités dans la ville grands sapin
illumination ou encore artisanat d'hiver
était au programme un cocktail féérique
pour ravir les habitants venus en nombre
malgré la pluie on commence à profiter
tranquillement des préparatifs de Noël
se mettent un peu dans l'ambiance voilà
c'est un beau marché qui est bien décoré
donc on tous les ans on vient ici et on
en profite avec les petits animaux les
chevaux j'ai eu une miniation le Père
Noël bah pour les enfants les la mini
ferme là comme ils font et tous les
exposants
le Père Noël pour les enfants qui est
très attendu un marché où chacun a ses
préférences
tu peux faire sur le marché de Noël bah
les bonbons au total 28 particuliers et
producteurs locaux ont répondu présent
plusieurs exposants venaient d'ailleurs
de Coignières c'était une volonté de la
municipalité sur mon stand j'ai tout un
tas de produits de la rue en fait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec avec tout ce qu'on
connaît en pénurie de d'énergie et tout
ça c'est important et puis ça permet
aussi de faire vivre les petites les
petites communes d'avoir une activité
locale sur les petites communes il y a
des sapins de Noël fait avec du coton
démaquillant et après dessus je rajoute
des décos j'aime bien l'ambiance de Noël
et puis et puis c'est sympa c'est
familial sans oublier bien sûr le Père
Noël venu tout droit de Laponie je viens
rendre une petite visite à mes futurs
mes futurs petits enfants que je vais
livrer gentiment que je vais pouvoir
récolter un peu des idées pour prévoir
la construction au niveau des lutins
avec une question que l'on tous est-ce
que les enfants étaient sages cette
année tous même les plus grands donc il
y aura énormément de cadeaux en
attendant les nombreux cadeaux sous le
sapin d'autres rendez-vous festifs sont
prévus dans le département prochaine
date le marché de Noël de la Ferme du
Manet à Montigny-le-Bretonneux du
vendredi 2 décembre au dimanche 4
décembre
[Musique]